well throughout the Michael Flynn saga
many assumed that Flynn was spied on and
then unmasked by half the Obama
administration due to the faceless
surveillance of the Russian ambassador
but a recent really interesting piece of
national review by frequent show guest
Andy McCarthy makes a really interesting
a really a compelling claim he says that
Flynn's phone call was never unmasked at
all instead McCarthy argues the facts
point to another weirder possibility
that the CIA was spying on Flynn's call
and never followed fiesel restrictions
in the first place Matt Whittaker is
former acting Attorney General and
offered the brand-new book above the law
the inside story of how the Justice
Department tried to subvert President
Trump
Matthew Whitaker joins us tonight thanks
so much for coming on so what do you
make of this theory that the CIA ignored
FISA and just spied on Flynt
well as you point out because he was not
unmasked there was no request from the
time of that phone call in on December
29th until really the White House
meeting on January 5th when ultimately
the White House chief of staff requested
unmasking of general Flynn there has to
be some other explanation because on
January 3rd of 2017 Andy McCabe went to
the National Security Division had at
DOJ Mary McCourt and said essentially
the contents of the call and so there is
a period of time from the 29th of
December of 16 until that meeting
between Makeba McCourt where someone
told McCabe and then McCabe transmitted
that information so and there's no
unmasking in that period of time so it's
very right curious to say the least so
you were in the Justice Department
explain to us non-lawyers would it be
legal for the CIA to spy on American
citizens and then just leaked what they
found to other agencies and the media
the short answer is no there are
constitutional tenants here that are at
play now this happened while mr. Flynn
was out of the country and we don't
specifically know where the ambassador
to Russia was located may have been in
DC may have been in Russia so this may
have been intercepted by the CIA under a
different program or by a friendly third
third-country but the biggest concern is
exactly what you point out which is this
constitutional that it violates the
Fourth Amendment it violates all sorts
of policies and procedures but
nonetheless On January 30 a mccabe had
essentially the transcript of verbatim
of this call no elected leader can run a
country in which the biggest law
enforcement in cell agencies operate
independently in violation of the
constitution democracy dies under those
circumstances so we have to fix this it
doesn't seem like anyone's really
working to fix it please reassure me
that someone is because I just don't see
it well the Constitution is
ever-renewing and those we continue to
live under those and we do need our
elected and appointed executive branch
officials including the intelligence
agencies to follow basic tenets of
constitutional law it is your right this
country will suffer and suffer greatly
if we don't get back to that being the
fundamental basis of all of these
surveillance programs and making sure
that the law and the Constitution is
followed every single time because
unlike Mitch McConnell Democrats just
don't mess around at all if a Democrat
is elected president next time one is I
think it's gonna fire everybody and put
their cousins in charge of these
agencies well hopefully from this
painful chapter that we've experienced
over the last three years really since
the transition of power in 2016
to the Trump administration the
intelligence agencies have lacked some
adult supervision I think we are seeing
folks put in by the Trump administration
but there's no promise that when Biden
you know if he were to get elected would
put adults in charge of the Intelligence
Agency right no he put loyalists in
charge should be afraid not to and
that's when things just called that's
when we just get fully third-world at
that point I think Matt Whittaker thank
you so much Congrats on the new book
Thank You Tucker